[موسيقى]
الجزيره العربيه
كان يغيب عنها التدوين في فترات زمنيه
سابقه او انها تقريبا تمتد الى الف سنه
تقريبا اهملت في هذا الجانب لكن الشعر
جاري على اللسان اهل الجزيره العربيه
والشعر كان هو الوسيله الاعلاميه والوثيقه
التاريخيه الداله على حياه المجتمع في تلك
الفتره حيث ان القصائد تحتوي على دلالات
وتحمل رؤى معينه وتعكس حياه اجتماعيه او
سياسيه جرت على اهل هذه الجزيره العربيه
ولذلك هي مهمه وكنز اغفل في فترات زمنيه
سابقه
[موسيقى]
الرواد
الله يرحمهم جميعا وحتى الشعر الجنوب هل
كانوا على موقف واحد من الافاده من الشعر
الشعبي
تقريبا لم يتم
الغوص في النصوص الشعريه باستخراج
دلالاتها الكامله او تحقيقها وانما كان
همم تعاملهم تقريبا تعامل سطحي مع اراده
النص كما هو
[موسيقى]
في نصوص عندنا طلعناها لها 600 سنه 700
سنه 400 سنه فهذه لها دلالات معينه وكان
ان الناس ترى انه اقصى حد للنصوص الشعريه
العام 200 سنه ولكن بالبحث والتحقيق
ومقارنه بين المخطوطات طلعناه عظيمه